this is gonna be incredible I'm gonna
tell wardrobe to get me a gown like
James Brown wore in the Blues Brothers I
love that big badass with it Aaron hey
what's going on they give they give such
you're on my phone yeah I liked Billy it
better when he was a country singer I'm
sure we've seen a lot of that do I like
him more when he was singing the country
music what did we like say that was just
my clanking pressure why do you always
leave Sundance's Mack Sennett when I get
out ha ha that's funny
my brain just exploded live show what's
happening is a van cool are they cool
super cool look at them they're hanging
out it's Nate cool back there hey okay
Oh Oh your flowers just for me today
just trying to be like you and I grow up
little stuff just the little things just
the smidge it's the little stuff ha ha
ha ha what are you doing happy I'm happy
you're always laughing you always make
me smile when I see you good you make
things up too I'm not going out through
that door that stuff that way is good
this Way's good hey we want to live here
something I do you know just about
basically is your bedroom like back that
way
you